in the Philippines trans people are
culturally visible right we're part of
mainstream culture yeah we're not
politically recognized there are no
rights you know for gender recognition
policy but when they moved to America it
was the other way around I was legally
recognized as a woman in my f but there
was no cultural visibility thus you know
when I moved to New York City in 2005
I had to go stealth you know where my
mother would say it still yeah and you
know in the book and Horace Barbie I
detailed sort of like I felt like now I
look back
why I like the Spy genres because I felt
like I was a spy in the kind of a secret
agent exactly for eight years biggest
secret ever yeah in that moment in in
the book Because as a fashion model
I entered this industry that is all
about the power of imagery but I was not
being seen every day of my life for
eight years it was this constant
um I was so visible right I was in
Congress of magazine billboards
but I was also consciously invisible at
the same time